how do we know our own writing level the
level that we're at we all think were
good at something or excellent at
something we see the world through a
certain lens it fits together with our
experiences so we think we're making
sense we think it's brilliant in terms
of our life experience but how do we
really know or maybe we won't
I don't think you should know you're one
of the few in the class who are really
good because that's kind of putting a
cap on yourself oh I I would say and we
do talk about this I'm when I point out
to them in terms of as we're
workshopping everybody's work and yes
everybody's at different levels that I
say we all come to this room from
different places we all have been
writing for different periods of time
some are closer to the beginning than
others some have already done some stuff
sold some stuff so it's going to be we
have we're making allowances for that
that nobody will be on the same level
and I would say that I would just say
don't worry about your level it's not
relevant to the process of learning to
master a craft and you know in a
difficult craft at that that just do the
work in front of you bu and write what
you have to write because the thing
ultimately with writing and then the you
know the beauty of it is even when a
story is derivative perhaps you've got
an idea for a plot be saying yeah no no
no I you know I've seen that the score
of times before or through the decades
kind of stuff and I would say yes but no
one can write it exactly the way you
would write it
it's not about level it's about
individual point of view and insight
into the human condition and that is I
would say an all-time on all things in
it for all times it is to be encouraged
that's what we do we seek ourselves in
what we write even even when we're
writing for money for pay and you can
overdo that but I think you need to be
doing it some of that in absolutely
everything you write because what was
that that was some some book came out
and in the 1930s I forget who wrote it
who said there are basically thirty
thirty six plots in all of literature
that's it well that's what the thing is
with genre
you know genre you're gonna write or
western well that's been done a few
hundred a few thousand times
hasn't it well you will do it your way
you will do it the way in which it has
not been done before or if that's not
how it turns out keep working on it if
you wish or put it in the drawer and you
will have learned some lessons about
writing and yourself along the way but
I'm the level thing you know it's just
that we running different races you so
much levels you know it's like some
people started sooner than other people
so of course they're going to be ahead
but I would admonish writers neophytes
and and experienced ones don't worry
about that you can make yourself nuts
worrying about the level because you
will always be writing what you want to
write unless you get hired to do it for
a job but you will be writing what you
want to write the way you want to write
it now just work to make it the best you
can make it be that's all
and one day you may surprise yourself
just when you think maybe you aren't so
good and this happened oh we all go in
cycles yeah this this should be
mentioned - I mean you know up one day
and down the next day suicidal I mean I
mean this is art this is writers you
know welcome to the club
on that big wheel the emotional journey
of what it is what we do but you are
also learning whether this art form is
for you or not along the way
are you in for the long haul that's the
only question you need to keep asking
yourself am I getting enough food out of
this enough creative food and juice and
sense of you know that growing sense of
command incremental command of a much to
be respected craft that can be quite
intricate that I'm hooked that this is
what I need I mean it has been said that
you know for writers it hurts more not
to do it than to do it are you up for a
lifetime of all the range of emotions
you are going to be going through as a
writer as an artist does this what you
want to do really they want to be an
artist that's great but understand that
it is not the simple an easy choice to
make in life quite the contrary
but it is a fabulous fabulous journey
unlike unlike any other I think
you